[Musik]
ich drücke drauf während sie haben oder
es muss ja heute habe ich einen gast
hier ist der freddy denn kennt ihr alle
schon im stehen und wie sonst vor allem
die kinder sind bald zurück die queen
wird die hinterher tagen aufgeregt weil
der sturm ii zu gast hier ist und so
besuch und ich bin echt ganz fotos sind
in den ferien kommt denn dann werden sie
morgens schon um 8 auf der matte und
wollen mit ihr zocken
er will mit dir in kinder zu hause
spielen und rutschen und gemein kraft
ja man das ja das machen wir alles noch
ja ich würde gerne mit dem backen weil
du für mich mein großes backbord so
einfach nochmal nehmen jetzt dreimal
hintereinander schneiden und einfach
mein gesichtsausdruck daneben dass die
ware war und ich hab mal ne frage ist
der gerne kuchen torten du ja das trifft
sich glaube ich ganz gut was ist denn
deine lieblings klassische torte also
zum klassiker hat dänemarks richtige
obama zeit versuchen voll
also ich würde ja genau ich würde folgen
so schwarzwälder kirsch kirsch
reinkriegt es ist eine torte man sagt
schwarzwälder kirschtorte schon weil das
schwarzwälder kirschkuchen hört sich
blöd an
für mich ist alles torte was mit sahne
creme oder butter ok buttercreme war
auch für mich als ich das erste mal
selber gemacht hat eine enttäuschung
aber ich muss zugeben für mich auch
damals oder ja ich weiß
99 29 gewonnen nein nein nein nein das
war einfach nur es war einfach nur
mutter und dann was sahne oder so und
pudding oder pastor realisiert hat dass
da wirklich noch nicht mutter tanja ich
dachte es wäre er seine weißt du wie so
oft ist so eine gängige phrase
buttercreme es hat dann die konsistenz
aber eigentlich ist es in wirklichkeit
so sei bei dem du knete ist und dann
irgendwie aus marokko lieber einfliegen
lässt und dann wird es einen kuchen drin
aber näher sein vierter ja sag was
unsere mutter konsum
ich verstehe auch eigentlich wie ihr
alle hier so aussieht das ist echt so
woran liegt sport macht ihr das zusammen
einfach gute laune gute gehen wir denken
uns die kalorien mac ok oder oder alle
hier immer so bei der arbeitszeit
okay wir können an schwachstellen da ja
jetzt sommer so richtig so basic und ich
habe gedacht wir machen daraus ein naked
cache und es ist so so die klassische
schwarzwälder kirschtorte modernisiert
und ganz einfach machen dass man bei der
blick wirklich nichts falsch machen kann
geil oder 44 100 prozent bin ich dabei
ich habe zufällig papis gut böden
gebacken hat die neben oder soll ich dir
zeigen wie man bis irgendwann los mal
die neben zufällig sogar show geboten wo
kann man das so sehen
vieles habe ich schon online ok so
ansonsten stehen wir das haus hat er
abgesagt
ansonsten gibt es das dritte ich weiß
gar nicht was hochladen deswegen ich
aber basic biscuit und wenn man sagt hey
ich möchte kurz eine torte backen aber
ich habe nicht so viel zeit man kann ja
bis mit kaufen aber das finde ich ganz
schlimm weil es trocken immer dass immer
dann trocken und wahnsinn so drei
zutaten eier zucker mehl und weil wir
noch eine vierte zu tat und das ist eine
prise glück also schwarzwälder kirsch
machen wir die kühlung und die sahne und
dann dr
ok ich hoffe ihnen zutaten
[Musik]
ok also nehmen wir schattenmorellen wenn
ihr 60
warum heißen die schattenmorellen es
wirklich nicht das habe ich voll
interessieren weil das eigentlich im
schatten burschen in wasser darf ich
letztens ganz viel ärger bekommen für
leuten von leuten ich habe das
kirschwasser weg kündigt haben die
gesagt macht so dass sofort bitte mit
sprudel voll und trinkst das
kirschwasser ich gesagt ich habe eine
schwere allergie dann wie gesagt warum
machst du dann damit er wie gesagt
stimmt natürlich schattenmorellen auch
große langelott kirche oder nordkirche
ist eine sorte der sauerkirschen
sie gehört zur familie der rosengewächse
rosazea und die und ist die am meisten
angepflanzten sorte
sie ist eine späte sorte und bringt hohe
erträge der baum ist recht anspruchslos
wächst auch im schatten gut und streckt
viele früchte anspruchslos im tschad
anspruch nur ein thema wissen warum weil
die sorte ertragreich ist und günstig
ist wenn baum dann dieser jetzt
alte kirchen und schwarz lackiert drin
lassen möchte und nicht drin lassen
haben wir diese zutat
das video wird etwas anders als sonst
hey was du meinst cooler viel cola chef
und spontaner ja ja also wir haben wir
40 gramm stärke 70 gramm zucker ein glas
schattenmorellen weil sie ein schatten
wachsen
eine prise zitronen und abregnen prise
zimt und etwas wandel extrakt hier noch
ein video offen bei mir da wollte ich
deinen kühlschrank richtig einsortieren
video nachstellen weil ich habe keine
ahnung wo sagte kühlschrank kommt ja die
kommen einfach nur bei mir da rein weil
das erdöl das musst du ja das macht voll
spaß
na ja ich sag mal immer der der radius
wo weiter mit ich drücken
der radius bei der welt den sparten spaß
es macht spaß ich halt meint ja sagst du
stärke zucker in den topf geben
einfach so ja herr frank nicht anmachen
erstmal erstmal noch gar nichts aber
rein ja nicht 7
es wird jetzt wie so eine apotheke
gekocht wieder probleme ich habe das
schon sehr viel politische macht schon
ist das ein problem soll dann den
kirschsaft den kirschsaft krieg
hinterachse oder passt es nur auf ich
guck mal wie weit ich kriege das hin
ich muss einfach schnell schützen das
ist glaube ich das thema und so länger
unseren dank niemand zum leid mehr druck
als beim abi gerade gehabt
das fühlt sich an wie für die
matheklausur hatte war es doch nur eine
5 plus aber es hat gereicht es gut aus
du schaffst es
und nicht das weiß genau wer sonst ist
bitter beim weißen habe nämlich schön
mit kaviar letztens gemacht mit zitronen
soße war schön viel weiß es von der
zitrone war nämlich schön zitrone mit
mit peter soße dann herbert uhling
kinect aber kein leck robert so nadja
vanille oder ware jetzt bin ich mal hier
jetzt nicht fragen okay wer weiß nicht
ist eine große debatte ich dachte du
hättest du das schön das thema besiegelt
manila extrakt vanille extrakt schon ein
schuss was ich mache immer ein bisschen
mehr als ein täter fühlen ja weil dann
ist es richtig geht der alarm
ja ja ja ist auch so wow da passt und
mit prise zimt
es ist ein privileg lasst uns nicht
stimmig ist jetzt gerade so die
beziehung zwischen euch ich diese
recherchen ich sage ich mache ich beide
fertigt der youtube wir haben uns
eigentlich das eigentlich ein blind date
her okay wir haben uns auf parship de
von berlin es ist ein monitor niedrigen
werde es ist man fast nur auf geld von
elitepartner start reinreden lassen ins
mikrofon
die technik dankte hallo hallo hallo ich
bin musst du musst ein bisschen flüsse
aber dann hat man noch den unglaublichen
sms pack krass was ist dass dessen gerät
nespro fest aus oder credits sachen wo
ich mich frage warum brauchen wir das
und dann braucht man noch mal wir haben
werde ich für saison ja ich gehe das
begehrte der gärtner war immer entweder
der mörtel oder die erfahrung
das weiß im raum stehen also einen
teelöffel wer schon jetzt ein halber
teelöffel macht nur eine dreh so ganz
wenig nutzen weil das ist kein pressen
lassen
ich habe den jungs gefunden ernsthaft
jakub krise kann ich aber inzwischen
ganz gut
jetzt führen
genau das ist ja noch nicht an jetzt ne
erholt und man kann was andere so eine
große aufgaben lassen
ich weiß noch nicht wie lange du wirst
mich nicht angemacht
bringt das eigentlich was mit dem
abziehen runden acht sparen ja aber wo
ist fredy bickel
hallo liebe schnitt abteilung ich hätte
gern eigenen dinge ich sehe euch das
auch gerne ein paar euro ist ready gehen
wir mit power power boost freddy wer hat
mal auf der förderung hat weil er ist
verbrannt august reddig wersauer
august werde ich hier verkürzt ich sage
wenn ihr mal ein paar daran kriegt die
sagen wir wollen nur große power fuß
machen und aktionsfelder da sagt beruf
der mich sofort an
ich mache das hing groß dem was man hat
noch nie so schnell gekocht nur mit mir
auf 200 grad wollt ihr eure nudel mal
nicht in elf minuten al dente haben
sondern den zwei power boost denke das
ist okay so oder mehr
das ist okay so
das sieht gut aus das sieht gut aus
jetzt gab es doch die noch mit rein
geben jetzt alle ja einfach schön und
dann unterheben ja wir haben richtig
runter ist mit ja seminare ich will hier
gar nicht so viel beifall du machst du
so schön so wie du das machst das ist so
wie bei der enr wenn sie kleine kinder
sind die sprechenden wort falsch aus er
sagt zum beispiel immer mama mir ist so
langweilig
das sage ich auch immer langweilig
wusste doch vier jahre und dann will ich
sie nicht korrigieren und nicht sagen
ein reißender vor weil langweilig fand
ich hätte das immer damals mit den toten
hosen
ich hätte einfach immer zu den toten
hosen konnte ich nicht aussprechen ganz
lange früher habe ich immer die
wortlosen mit anderen ersten und
tragische moment gewesen hat viel vor
hat viel kaputtgemacht aber auch für
viele sachen den weg gegeben hat dem
moment und dann sind das so sachen wie
will man nicht korrigieren weil sie
einfach so also ich finde das gut
also ich habe schon mehrfach öffentlich
über meine erziehungsmethoden gesprochen
wenn ich später mal kinder habe und da
sind schon so sachen bei also ich glaube
ich schon viele spiele laufen das machst
du schon alles richtig
ich habe immer gesagt ich bringe meinen
kindern weil das den zwiebeln april ist
ein apfel zwiebel und dass sie dann
irgendwann wenn sie in die welt
entlassen werden mit dieser enttäuschung
wieder kommen das ist ja einfach sieben
jahre lang verarscht habe und das will
ich einfach nur sagen so das ist die
welt so funktioniert das hier alles und
das war nur noch jubel also sei
vorsichtig voll gerne aber jetzt weiß
ich dass die kläger auch nicht sooo süß
sein muss weil das hier auch schon fix
genug ist voll aber etwas abkühlen
lassen
ein bisschen komponente 1 war der
biscuit den haben wir fertig das
komponente zeit die füllung und was wird
noch die sahne
wir machen es einfacher wir machen
vielleicht quark sahne
na ja einfach an ist einfach ich hole
ich hole die zutaten so ein
spezialgebiet du darfst zustanden
vorstellen
okay da fange ich natürlich total gerne
mit an
wir haben hier zum einen quark 200 gramm
des internats 500 gramm puderzucker 50 g
vanille make sally überall erhältlich wo
es vanilla extra gibt seine versteckte
sachen dieses versteckte fifa ist das
hier auch soja dass man weiß was es ist
sonderbar zum saga schlagen sind wir
cool mit ja wir sind cool mit küche die
machen auch esspapier kennst das ist
okay wir sind recht cool mit denen
schenk mal was zu die schickt mir das
dann das sind leute die sowas sehen
jetzt bin ich unter druck bei mir ist
immer so keine ahnung das beste was bei
mir passiert ist war einfach nur am
nachricht so hey ich bin wo ich gucke
deine videos das war das beste was mir
jemals passiert das aber küche wendy s
papier haben zehnmal geiler tattoo es
natur irgendeinem diese tattoos machen
sagt ja auch so dass ich glaube keiner
daran
okay wir sind selbst verändern also da
mein nächster hat übrigens keinen 900
noch können
warum nicht thomas eigene produktion
muss dafür meine ganzen produkte immer
so einen warum aus piepsen ja also ich
würde nicht so nennen wir meinen dass
schon ein bisschen action
ich habe aber keinen namen ist auf ihr
konto sondern vorab sprechen ich das
überrascht von dem ergebnis
ich würde den
früher ihnen herr der ringe okay gesagt
sag ich dir sagen wie ja aber wenn du
nach hause gehst musst es dir da
vergessen
ok ich finde es nämlich lustig wenn du
sagen erstellt also quark kommt hier
rein
da findet es lustig wenn die sahne
schlagen kann sie so gut seien
erschlagen
ich habe so lange becher und dann gehen
immer meine komische stabmixer kaputt
weil immer sehr warm werden und ich
deshalb schon den dritten stabmixer in
drei monaten das kann ich nicht gut aber
es klappt ich hatte mal du hattest auch
mit einem stabmixer mit dem schnitt ist
total gerührt die nicht so warm war
ja das kann sein und da hat sich das
hier so einmal komplett verdreht und so
sieht jetzt lustig auslesen der schnee
für schnee und sahne höher oder wie ich
ihn nenne den butter besen hat seinen
namen nicht alle ehre gemacht
ästhetisches anders habe ich bei dir
gesehen ist immer sehr ist ja schwäbisch
okay lasst ein bisschen schwäbisch bis
nach gekratzt damit auch alle register
ziehen bad ischler sorry schwere ich mir
[Gelächter]
deswegen ist ein halber lacht na ja das
mache ich doch mal gold ja ich weiß ich
bin ja halber schraube in neckarsulm
warum setzt man nicht ein video vor das
gesicht wahren
ein bissle mehr habe zum zuschauer hatte
sich vorbei
das ist schon jetzt haben sie alle
abgeschaltet jetzt da sind wir frei
geblieben ich hatte ja ich hatte ein
paar kleinen mitbringen sollen einfach
rein und damit haben ja jetzt erst mal
verrühren bis sich der bruder zu kommen
quark verbunden hat langsam dazu einfach
die sonne langsam dazu die sorte
carlisle
bei schlagsahne immer auf dem
kühlschrank hhs wussten nämlich dass
entweder wahrscheinlich an einer immer
war das immer weiter er wird dafür
anrichten und zutaten und so häufig kann
hier noch eine baumaschine
das wären pro 100 scheine aber ein
bisschen einmal kurz auf den rund 100
vereinen zusammengespannt nur einer drin
2 das hat das schneebesen und andere
sind die rührbesen bei risen 2
bearbeiten dann so den drei gelitten und
schnee wir sind der hat er einen großen
raum lösen
vom 9 ja aufpassen dass man nicht zu
lange röhren und schneller und aber auch
nicht nee das passt so ok
hainburg aber bewusst immer alles sehr
behutsam ja so vorsichtig und so schön
langsam die luft einschlagen
macht man nicht den kopf trifft das
machst du nur einmal mit sagen dann
nicht mitmachen aber bei seiner
ehrlichen charakter
ja es gab auch die kamera aus weil ich
bin ich tiefer wenn das mal nicht machen
weil du siehst durch das fett kann die
halle schon wächst noch ok aber wenn sie
so ist sie perfekt also nicht mehr
weiter würden ok jetzt stell dir kurz
kalt räum hierauf und noch platz für den
enke zu tun hat und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder und jetzt youtuber
übergang
ach so ja was geht da dekorieren also
freddy dekoriert jetzt und wir haben ja
eine schoko biscuit da möchte so
wegschneiden klar wie auch immer zweimal
durch recht schalten immer hier so fest
zu ja aber dann schneidet man sich doch
etwas ab nein weil das ist so traut der
ist nicht nur am ende mit der hand so
bisher dagegen
wir unterstützen hahahaha
und dann hier nochmal knuspert das hat
zwei schichten dem häuschen sind rein so
und dann noch mal einfach durch ihr
einfach so nicht verstellen
[Musik]
weißt du was wir machen wir machen eine
richtig coole naked orte wir nehmen
jetzt noch bisher schon jetzt nehmen wir
noch den hund dann müssen wir einfach
dann wird es ja sehr hoch da machst du
denn aber so trocken und nachts kannst
du aber so taten sehen cool aus wenn sie
hoch sind damit kann man echt
beeindruckend
ok com hier ist deine taten drehte dann
antwortet dann rutscht nicht und dann
nimmst du am besten den deckel also
einen trockenen deckel ok und dresden um
den dann können wir später den boden der
schön gerade ist als abschluss nehmen
aha ab seite und ließ die tricks der
szene hier spritzbeutel stellen ja oder
auch ein sehr großer coup eine
spritztour seiner runde und es so große
schneiden kann
es ist perfekt daraus waren sind so
kleine sachen tui und dann schlägt hat
es hier so irgendwas nicht ausgeht klar
habe mir die leute gesagt dass ich
faszinierend franken wir den sack geht
auf den walzen genau weiß man das nicht
machen die leute freestyler mit zu hause
noch kein sally krug haben und jetzt
ach so dass darüber wusste ich natürlich
genau das gemeint ist so und dann einmal
eine perfekte sahne durchgemacht hast
mein gott ja das ist natürlich auch wer
mich kennt weiß zwei sachen sind sind es
ist seine der hammer das ist sein und
das ist pizza das sind meine beiden
top-fonds im kommt dass oder mehr
das passt zum geschmack gekommen zu sein
gestand einst dann nochmal ja alles noch
so wie das auch noch für den chor die
hier erwartet
für die für die deg und 15
ja sagt er das ist mein sohn und dem
baby bestand spitznamen bei freddy
worauf also ja okay gut und dann oben zu
drehen so und dann so leicht 100 rücken
genau da hat mal eine hand oben die
drückt also die übt den druck aus und
die andere unten die führt und jetzt
stürzt durch die außen herum sondern
ring am stück am stück oder abgesetzt
okay heute sagt tui unterbricht das so
ja und dann drehe ich das so dabei oder
ich drehe ich mache wie beim töpfern
gehören ja sagen wir mal bis auf den
fehler den du ist eingebrochen war
wirklich fantastisch und dann den rest
davon dabei sieht hammer aus
ich finde das gut ist dann unser rezept
dass er unser retter
ich habe die rezepte der stadt rain
freddy snowbike potato ein bild von der
kartoffel zehn minuten in wasser und
gucken was passiert leute so okay jetzt
aber gut dreht oben nochmal nach weil
ich die chance dort ist also druck
nachlässt und immer aufpassen dass du
mit den händen den die creme darin nicht
so warm machst ja okay also und darauf
rechts jetzt und dann drehst du wieder
noch mit teamwork und dann mache ich
wieder ja so bis dato noch okay dabei
wird zu sagen oder oh gott oh gott ich
habe hier bei marit hat sich vor
wechseln
ach du heiliger oh gott ich weiß nicht
wie ich hier genau drücker aber
irgendwas kommt noch weiter raus es wird
unangenehm weil ich bin ich bei meinem
handgelenk angekommen und man einige ok
ja alles gut habe ich gemacht wurden so
schneller drehen ja und dann kannst du
immer wieder hier abstellen
manchmal beginnen ganz schöner trotzkopf
manchmal muss man manchmal frechdachs
sagt man vielleicht schon jetzt hier
live
das können doch manchmal ich habe das
auch okay
400 prozent und jetzt kann man ja
sowieso einen dunklen boden nehmen so
den aus der mitte zb erdrosselt und wenn
man eigentlich mal schwarzwälder
kirschtorte mit kirschwasser machen dann
muss man solche böden trinken und die
creme und kirschwasser
ja ist schwierig aber so ist cooler habe
ich empfehle dieses rezept kriege ich
hin als normal
freilich den solex schon gut aus wenn
die wirklich so schön hoch sind also
schon vier was ist schon so so angeber
zählt das dann als hochzeitsgast
eigentlich so zwei kerzen darauf stelle
getan und feuerzeug mit oder so und dann
zur hochzeitstorte und sollen sogar
sättigend opfer vielleicht nicht mehr
[Gelächter]
aufsteht kaum weiter murat bitte ich dir
hier bald raus so ja es war ein toller
besucher das waren megatonnen besucht
weiß ehrlich nicht ja und auch recht
gott oh gott was passierte gerade gottes
ich aus meinem lebenslauf immer wieder
mit unterbringung in der mitte wird
immer schwierig
das ist ein kleiner turm aber mal ganz
ehrlich muss man es wirklich zum
spritzig machen wenn man segel streicht
das ist schon einfach nur noch ja
eigentlich ist hat dafür durchaus
wichtig sind gleichmäßig das stück links
dem balkon der terrasse mal irgendwie
schön über die weltkugel entstehen ganz
neue video ideen im kopf
das schlimmste war die hilfe youtube
hinter der szene aufgebaut haben
wie halte ich den schritt lassen sie
sich doch einfach mal eine basic serie
hofft dass er die webseite mal keine
ahnung habt aber auch weiterkommen
freuen im leben ich habe früher mal
praktikum in der küche gemacht
ja und danach habe ich mir eine sache
geschworen nie irgendwas in meinem leben
bekochen zu machen
guckst du mal was mein wort wert ist zu
mir selber so probiert es mal so
du musst es extra schneller
was kann man da schon zweimal
unterbrochen gewesen und mein gott ich
weiß nicht mehr was to them to get to
okay dass zweimal der gleichen stelle
wie ist das denn passiert und total ist
jetzt noch sind hat einen deckel drauf
und aber upside down genau umdrehen
einmal einmal klappen ok upside down so
dass ich sehr gut aus und auch schon
wieder so groß muss man einfach mal
sagen wenn man so nah davor steht das
ist wirklich niemand direkt mit ein
bisschen mut kriegen kann wenn man immer
aber ist doch gut gepasst so aufgehen
ist das dein ernst gerade sie ist gerade
[Gelächter]
wir schneiden dem jetzt anders
[Musik]
das schon sammer
du bist doch was gut ist das normal
waren sie doch jetzt gerade sagte das
ist der mond das ist der falsche weg
wenn wir das machen würde läge ja wir
sind wahrscheinlich kaufen
das ist schon gut
das ist doch nicht dafür da ist die
reine mitgehen aber warum denn es macht
doch keiner also sorry da alles andere
hier geil ich atme gerne die luft wo es
hell die draufsteht auf den wirklich
ganzen heranzoomt aber das hier doch da
wo sie ein schreiben dadurch raus keiner
markttiefe torten doch den pisa jetzt
probiere noch mal zurück zu vermerken
ist gerade ist gut gemacht und wir
zeigen wir nehmen einfach rest krämer
hier so dran und es wird also gestrichen
ja aber man sollte bilden kann auch
durch sehen okay das ist immer so
perfekt perfekt aussieht genau wann ist
diese snack dinge gewesen war schon ein
bisschen her als das so hochgekocht ist
weil jemand mal rezepte gefunden vom
paar jährchen
aber es muss halt schon auf der einen
seite perfekt sein perfekt in perfekt
was ist das jetzt für ein gerät die
zeitkarte damit kannst du dich
einstreichen und teig schneiden sagen
wir mal ist es hart auf hart kommen ja
loch in der wand spachtelmasse es muss
dringend ja er ist schon einfach nur
länger verspachtelt habe ich verstanden
hier muss ich wieder sehr gut wenn ich
voll an bord weil das hat so die
position suspect für mich ist klar
und jetzt noch bis an die oberfläche
[Musik]
warum genau weil dann siehst du wo die
kranken geht manch wurde kukksi mal
gegen wohl doch nicht so wie bei jedem
normalen mensch aber selbst ich kriege
eine glatte oberfläche hin auch wenn es
nur zehn minuten länger dauert als bei
euch aber kein problem
auch menschen können sich in diesem
format hier durchsetzt da durch neue
muster reinmachen vermute musste mein
spezialgebiet jetzt machst du kreis und
ich bin ich
ja gut ok dass wir ne es die torte die
tic tac schwarzwälder kirsch haben wir
machen auch gutes glas und dann ich zeig
dir jetzt den trick dann gleich dann ist
das ding hier die perfekte torte wir
müssen sie nur kurz kühlen weil hier
drin hat sie die 80 grad nicht merkt
schon ich ja perfekt sie sogar sagt sack
und starben
überlege ich mir während welcher
aufräumen wie wir sie weiter dekorieren
denn ich habe aber keine
das heißt wir sehen uns gleich wieder
vielleicht schlecht mit den ach so macht
man das ja mal so drunter und dann ich
habe halt nur von dir zwei von diesen
ganzen langen die so klug machen wir mal
lustig ist nicht geschehen und das mit
den anderen deshalb viel viel challenger
und die anderen sind halt länger und
dann hast du ja ja ist aber federn so
und dann jetzt reißen sie die stimme von
der schokolade ab und ich stehe dann
nach und nach die kirchlichen 28 aktien
machen
jaja steckt sich kleine immer noch
hinter der kamera so mega schwierig
zeigte man mit dem recht einfach da
kannst du so ansetzen
unsere kasse röllchen machen aber sind
wir mal ganz ehrlich dass er schon eine
arbeit die man sich damit macht ne und
kommt dann hier beide seiten das ist
zum kuchenessen projekt leute selbst
wenn der boden fertig ist dauert stunden
aber kommen wir viel quatsch gemacht es
ist doch super ich sag doch gar nichts
dagegen
ich sage nur nehmt euch vier bis acht
stunden zeit jedoch voll cool aber haben
dann schon mal jemand auf die zu nicht
gesagt diese schokolädchen da unten die
daran gemacht hast bei so einem projekt
das es schon das geilste weil du dir
damit richtig mir gegeben hast du sollst
nicht lügen
auch die hineinhören auch keiner gesagt
meine show coaching sind schön
könnt ihr das bitte kommentieren das
heißt jetzt so als werden insider und
dann ist auch komisch wenn so
kontextuell nicht mehr passt schon mal
vor du bist besser dann stehen leute
haben die mannschaft gar nicht so
gewollt sind schön dass er auch was
haben sie gemacht
also wenn du dann diese show geräuschen
hast ich habe halt echt immer so warme
hände
nun berichtet das ziemlich schmerzen und
dann könnte vielleicht da unten so dran
drücken laut oder wie sieht es mit den
kirchen aus die einfach nur bauten drauf
mit den stilen ja voll will so simple
sachen eigentlich ganz gut muss ich ja
aus welcher werbung da war der käs mit
der pr-mann kirche wo einfach wir wieder
nicht wissen woher kommt die piemont
kirschen und wieder bei der wikipedia
exkurs mehr ach die große lüge um die
piemont kirche jetzt bin ich gespannt du
das wort piemont kirche ist eine
kirschtorte dieses namens existiert
nicht heute was lernte bei kirschen und
großen kirchen skandal aufgedeckt
richtiger kirchen von daher gerade öfter
ein wenn es heißt detektiv in celle
wir haben eine eigene tätig sein
heilige wurde detektiv assistenz er
heißt
[Musik]
nickelodeon einfach anrufen es sind
garagen mäßig wir müssen einfach nur
kurz reden animateure haben bestimmt
auch hier oben sitzen bei den ganzen
mitarbeitern und wenn wir bloß der
marcel der animiert daran und er so kurz
was denkt immer aber das ist aber weiß
aber nie kitschig das sieht er eher
zufällig aus zufällig tatort ist so
schön gemacht und dabei war es dann an
ist nicht bis an den rand genauso wie in
der mitte von unten nach oben strömt öl
aus
was sagst du hier zu haben mega ich
werde noch ein paar mehr
so ist eine tür gesperrt sein
seit die tanzfläche das war bereit
back to the major steht er jetzt drauf
mio
ich dachte steht mayonnaise mio
das ist richtig schön ich würde sagen
das ist definitiv die schönste
vorzunehmen der ich jemals stand und vor
allem mit diesem holz stecker hat das
ist dann so natur und so holz und
schwarzwald und kirschtorte und in
wenigen minuten habt ihr die perfekte
nobody like it almost like it und
bikinis bikini
die tat bikini schwarzwälder kirsch ja
ich muss sagen durch moderne stadt oder
fiel es mir auch zum glück kaum geholfen
ich hab nur moderat und
das ist immer wieder okay jetzt hätten
die zwei schwaben und die eine partnerin
großer unterschied
die torte worin liegt der unterschied
dass die partner besser anpacken
stuttgart ist aufgestiegen kann
wir reden auf meinem kanal nicht über
fußball dass wir politisch oder religiös
und ich sehr gut borussia
mönchengladbach champions league nach
begrüße genau ich bescheiden sie tut so
war das bei mir genauso zum glück selbst
verletzt die kirchen die und da musste
so machen so ok ich lass dir mal fallen
für den splash
das ist so geil und jetzt haarspray und
am bild leute eigentlich heißt es ja
ganz für die kirchen geil
das ist mir noch gemeint das könnte
könnte das können wir intern austragen
da hab ich nichts mehr zu tun haben wir
dann geschafft so richtig schön druck
jetzt gebraucht nur eine stunde fünf
stunden zusammengeschnitten ist an die
acht minuten lang mit rolls halten
mit kühl zeitungs los und so vier
stunden aber geht kosten schwarzwälder
kirsch habe ich heute noch mal die leute
glücklich gemacht
wow das ist neu und geil schwarzwälder
kirsch oder 10 15
ich finde außerdem von zehn kirschen
traditionelle ist einfach geil da biss
und die zwei biscuit farben finde ich
auch cool wenn du dir aufgefallen die
zwei bis gefahren war wollte ich gerade
ansprechen nachkommen und hast du dieses
diese dieser joghurt pudding creme
also ich bin jetzt zweites zum zweiten
mal als test dafür ist aber ich muss
sagen das ist baden hier wird gerade
sager sind
das ist klar einige sites zweimal im
warten aber das schönste
also dann von mir nach wie vor 10 von 10
kirchlich ja
zehn von zehn törtchen 915 von mir wegen
partner abzug den jockey salat der
kartoffel ich weil darüber die über die
kartoffel gibt nie zehn von zehn wären
was richtig gut ist die sagt immer das
beste was ich jemals hatte
neun tagen werden wir lebten weil die
möglichkeit etwas besseres zu bekommen
sollte immer da sein
er macht den weltbesten hockey sala ziel
von 7 punkte für diese schwarze so mega
und ihr ja ganz einfach naked cache
einfach modern und ihr habt die perfekte
hochzeitstorten falls sie zu hause
heiraten wollte vielleicht nun mal falls
falls noch mal die quarantäne kommen
sollte oder so dann könnte könnt ihr
jetzt zuschlagen zu hause schön antrag
machen wenn ihr das macht dann markieren
uns beide male auf institut auf dem
riems gemacht und dann machen wir
digital machen wir die trauzeugen für
definitiv sind also packt die torte
unbedingt nach und werden uns jetzt
gleich noch ein stückchen auf jeden fall
gehen wir uns offen und dann weiter dort
gerne richtig lust frühere
[Musik]